and we're back welcome to the show
everybody welcome to the new year happy
new year happy new decade unless you're
one of those pedantic jerks that likes
to claim that the new decade doesn't
really start until 2021 which is it's
really really brewed and outrageous by
the way if you're one of those people
going around saying that oh we're not in
the new decade yet it's like when I was
celebrating my birthday in October and
my wife said to me but your birthday
isn't until June and I said so what what
difference does that make
I'll celebrate my birthday whenever I
damn well please and we will celebrate
the new decade whenever we damn well
please we might celebrate the new
millennium next year we might celebrate
the year 3000 next year if we feel like
it because time is relative man but
anyway I I don't even see how the
pedantic jerks and I say this as a as a
pedantic jerk myself on apologetically
but I don't think that it's correct in
this case because if the year 2021 is
the actual start of the of the next
decade that means that this year 2020 is
a part of the teen's or whatever we call
the previous decade
but if 2020 as part of the teen's then
for instance 1980 is part of the 70s but
how would you react if someone said oh I
was born in the 70s and you said what
year and they said 1980 that doesn't
make any sense in what universe is 90 is
80 part of 70s it's not so we begin so
this is the new decade I just want to
put that put that dress and we begin the
new decade talking about what happened
this past weekend as I you know haven't
done a show until until Thursday so
haven't had a chance to talk about it
not a fun topic to start things off with
but it is important as you as you may
have noticed after the anti-semitic
attack in New York on Saturday and then
the church shooting in Texas on Sunday
this argument has been ignited again
about whether houses of worship places
where people of faith congregate should
have armed security and armed
congregants I think
as this debates happened over the last
few days it is very oddly timed to say
the least because of course the attack
in Texas was neutralized within seconds
by an armed volunteer security guard
named Jack Wilson so you think what is
there to discuss if he hadn't been there
many more people would have died he was
so they didn't and the math seems pretty
straightforward now of course you could
argue and we'll get more into this in a
second but you could argue that if the
heroic Jack Wilson wasn't there the
assailant might have still been taken
down by any of the other I think it was
five or six armed worshippers who got up
and and also drew their weapons and that
can be seen on video but their presence
deals another blow to the standard
anti-gun talking points that you always
hear surrounding these situations
because we're often told that the
problem with the good guy with a gun
strategy is that all of those gun-toting
good guys would turn a mass shooting
into a Wild West
you know shootout and there'd just be
bullets flying everywhere
now even if that were true even if it
were true that having good guys with
guns would turn it into a Wild West
shoot-out and there would be bullets
flying everywhere wouldn't that be
better than bullets flying only in the
direction of innocent bystanders because
that that's that's usually how this goes
there's a bunch of bullets flying but
they're only going in one direction and
that is in the direction of the innocent
people so I don't think anybody wants
Church to turn into a gunfight at OK
Corral but I would rather have that than
just an all-out slaughter I would rather
have that than the massacre at
Sutherland Springs where if you recall
last year or two years ago 26 people
were shot and killed at church now this
is a false choice anyway because in in
the case in Texas over the weekend there
was no gunfight
there was no Wild West shoot-out there
was no massacre on the level of
Sutherland Springs although although
three people were killed and that's
because a good guy returned fire killed
the bad guy immediately and the other
good guys with guns refrained from
spraying bullets all over the place you
know they didn't need to fire their
weapons and so they did and and that was
the end of it now you compare that with
the attack at a rabbis home in New York
on Saturday where this scumbag was able
to stab five people with a machete
before fleeing the scene unharmed
and without guns to protect themselves
the people in the home they were you
know reports tell us they were throwing
tables and furniture at the at the
assailant and then they they took down
his license plate as he rode away now
you know they weren't armed that's all
they could do and they responded
correctly given the situation but can
any rational person or any reasonable
person argue that that victims are
better off defending themselves with
furniture and with a notepad to write
down the guy's information when he
leaves is that is that is it better that
they defend themselves that way then
with a firearm no well I mean no
reasonable or rational person can argue
that but there are a lot of irrational
and unreasonable people who like to have
their voice heard especially on this
topic it seems to me that these are
indisputable facts
events of this weekend proven here are
the facts houses of worship or you know
places where we're faithful congregate
should be protected with guns members of
minority groups that are often the
target of violent attacks should protect
themselves with guns buildings that have
that house our children for eight hours
a day should be protected with guns now
I agree with the anti-gun crowd that
these kinds of measures should not be
necessary okay society should be safer
just as I agree with the feminists who
when we talk about women protecting
themselves and feminists will say well
women shouldn't have to protect
themselves from raping men because men
shouldn't be raping in the first place I
agree
they shouldn't be I agree that many
things happen in our world that should
not happen and our world should be
different from how it is and if there
were any reliable way any feasible way
to preempt all of these bad things
without using guns I'd be in favor of
that but there isn't so I'm not all of
these shoulds and shootings just don't
amount to anything
when the bad guy who shouldn't be bad
shows up in the place where he shouldn't
be to actually do the bad thing that he
shouldn't be doing with the gun that he
shouldn't have and there's a whole lot
of because there are times like that
where a whole lot of shootings are
happening and when that happens you're
not gonna stop the bullet that's flying
towards you're not gonna stop it by
talking about what should and shouldn't
be because when shouldn't becomes is
which it so often does in this fallen
world of ours the only thing you can do
is respond to the reality of the
situation yes should and shouldn't
shouldn't that's true but it is it is
happening you know should and shouldn't
these are good topics for campaign
speeches and John Lennon lyrics but
they're useless when the lead is
actually flying now this is just about
responding to what's actually happening
and that's when you need a guy a very
practical guy like Jack Wilson and you
need him to have a very practical tool
like a gun and that's just the way it is
whether we like it or not
and that should sort of be the end of
the conversation
all these yes all these bad things
should not happen but they do and they
will always happen until the end of time
and so we need to be prepared to respond
that should be it but it is the media is
predictably determined to find a
negative spin for the Jack Wilson story
because it's just it's it's it's a story
that's so devastating to their narrative
for all the reasons I've already
described and they're going to absurd
lengths to find this this negative spin
for example USA Today published an
editorial yesterday talking about the
truly terrifying aspect of the church
shooting now you would think that the
truly terrifying thing is that a bad guy
who went into a church to shoot it up
that's the terrifying thing but not
according to USA Today what's terrifying
to them is that so many parishioners had
the means to defend themselves
that's what's terrifying and we'll get
into that op-ed in a minute but first a
word from ring you know rings mission
speaking of being safer rings mission is
to make neighborhoods safer you might
already know about their smart video
doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there's a package
delivery or if there's a surprise
visitor or whoever you're gonna get an
alert you'll be able to see it on your
phone and and you could speak to them
you can do this all through your phone
we've had ring for a while now at our
house and you know for me the main thing
I like about it you know at least from
my perspective is just peace of mind
because when you're a homeowner and
you've got a family and all these
there's a lot of anxiety that comes with
it and just being able to keep an eye on
things wherever you are and you know you
could be 3,000 miles away and you said I
do this all the time let me just check
to see what's going on at the house and
you pull up ring and then there's also
convenience as well no we're you know if
you can't get to the door I know I could
still talk to whoever's there so peace
of mind security convenience exactly
what you're looking for in a product
like this certainly exactly what I was
looking for as a subscriber right now
you have a special offer on a ring
welcome kit
which is available right now at ring.com
slash Walsh
that's ring.com slash Walsh the kid
includes a video doorbell and a chime
Pro which is just what you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home today go to ring.com slash Walsh
that's ring.com slash Walsh
alright so USA Today reading now from
the article by Elvia Diaz this is what
it says Jack Wilson is a hero all right
it took him only six seconds to kill a
gunman at a Texas church saving
countless lives unfortunately that kind
of split-second heroism has been turned
into a PR tool by gun advocates the
reality of Wilson's heroism is a lot
more complex
he wasn't just an ordinary parishioner
as gun advocates may want you to believe
the churches volunteer security team
member is a firearms instructor gun
range owner and former reserve deputy
with a local sheriff's department
according to New York Times detailed
account in other words he's exactly the
kind of man you want around with a
firearm but we know nothing about the at
least six other parishioners who also
appear to draw their handguns at West
freeway Church of Christ in white
settlement Texas and that's terrifying
goes on a little bit later but have we
really reached a point when each of us
need to carry a firearm anywhere we go
gun advocates certainly think so they
point to Wilson in the new Texas law
that allows him to allows him and others
to carry firearms inside the church
president Donald Trump said as much on
Twitter Monday
yada-yada-yada so and so forth so this
is exactly what I'm talking about the
focus here is on should and shouldn't
rather than the reality the author says
have we really reached a point where you
know these churchgoers need to bring a
gun to church yes apparently we have
apparently we have reached that point
they needed to have a gun and they did
and if you want to say that's terrifying
then fine I agree if you want to say
it's terrifying and terrible that people
have to be armed wherever they go and
you know that you need to even think
about this when you go to church if
you're saying that's terrifying
then yeah I agree it kind of is you
could make it less terrifying for
yourself by equipping yourselves with
the mean to means to defend yourself
should should the necessity arise but it
is kind of a terrifying situation but to
say that it's terrifying that people who
needed to be armed to protect themselves
were armed to protect themselves that
makes no sense
would it have been better would it have
been less terrifying if the gunman was
the only guy with a gun in that church
what if you were in the church okay if
you were there the gunman is there
would you prefer that some of your
fellow parishioners have a gun or maybe
even that you have one or not if you
were all unarmed would you look around
while you're huddled under the Pew you
know just hoping that he doesn't come to
your aisle would you look around and say
thank God nobody else has a gun here of
course not
see the problem in this is this is what
the media is doing that what they've
always told us what they've promised
what they it seems like have hoped is
that you know in a situation where a
gunman shows up to a church in a place
like Texas and there are six or seven
people there carrying guns and they all
pull them out but the media has always
told us is that it's gonna turn into a
Wild West shoot-out
bullets flying everywhere and now
they're writing articles and op-eds
about it as if that's actually what
happened but it isn't those other gun
owners weren't responsible they pulled
their firearms didn't fire them and that
was it
what's terrifying about it no in fact if
you were worried about that happening
this should make you less terrified
because you see that you know if
somebody is a law abiding gun owner and
they're carrying a gun legally they they
probably aren't treating it like a toy
they probably know how to use it
you know there are probably responsible
people
because people who are irresponsible
don't know anything about guns don't
know how to use them don't know how to
respond in situations like this most of
those people aren't aren't legally
carrying guns alright let's let's move
on to Pope Francis Pope Francis visually
viciously assaulting a woman as the
media has framed it anyway
and I think it's appropriate that we
start the new year and the new decade
which it is a new decade with a
controversy like this I think it really
got things off on maybe not a good foot
but but inappropriate one given how
incredibly stupid I expect this year to
be so we get a very stupid controversy
to start things so here's the footage
that went viral yesterday if you didn't
see it
prompting lots of people to lash out at
the Pope and talk about how the Pope
assaulted somebody but this is Pope
Francis greeting a bunch of people I
think on New Year's Eve and then this
happened watch so there you go I first
of all I admit I have been tempted so
many times as a Catholic to respond
exactly that way during the you know the
Catholics we have the weird sign of
peace thing we do during church and and
that's what if you've never been to a
Catholic Mass it's it's right before
communion and you know if everyone the
first time going to Cathal Mass you all
you're always taken off-guard by this
because in the middle of the of the of
the mass just seemingly out of nowhere
right before communion everyone turns to
start shaking hands now a lot of what
you know you go to a lot of different
I've been to many Protestant churches
and often times they'll do a greeting
thing before church starts and I have to
say as a Catholic I I like I think that
approach makes a lot more sense if
you're gonna do the greeting and if
you're gonna do this they can turn to
your neighbor and say hello I'm not a
fan of it in general I'm not a fan of
forced greetings where somebody tells me
to turn to the person next to me and say
to them if I want to say hi to them I
will yeah I don't need you I'm not a
child I don't need you ordering me
around but if you're gonna do that it
makes sense to do it before the service
starts to do it it not even midway
through but like two-thirds of the way
through by the way hi hello I'm it it
does I'm not a fan of it I don't like
but you know my strategy during the sign
of the piece as an anti-social person
and also as a germaphobe I don't really
want to touch the clammy hands of the
person next to me so what I you know I
stand there stoic lead during the side
of the piece and I don't turn I don't
turn around at people behind me to shake
their hand because that's my right okay
bodily autonomy and but but then often
times somebody will you know if you
don't turn around to shake the hand of
the person behind you they'll tap on
your shoulder and then you kind of turn
around say peace be with you they're
trying to shove their sweaty hand into
yours and so many times I've wanted to
get away I've wanted to do that exact
thing that the Pope did and I feel like
this now gives me the license to do it
because as long as the if the Pope does
something then that means we can as
Catholics at least that's what everyone
that's what that's what every non
Catholic assumes everything the Pope
does is infallible and so just by the
Pope doing that that gives up that means
we all can slap whoever we want as
Catholics that's not really how it works
but I wish in this case it did work that
way
anyway the way the media has reported
this they make it sound like Pope
Francis like dropkick the woman they're
framing at which which which would have
been a sight to behold we have to admit
the New York Times headline is the New
York Times headline says Pope Francis
apologizes after slapping away a
clinging pilgrim slapping away
a clinging pilgrim now you hear that
headline you're imagining based on that
headline a maybe a young child and
tattered rags dusty and dirty from the
long journey on the holy pilgrimage
running up to hug the Pope
and the Pope just kicks them away oh
yeah get off me
you're dirty peasant but that's not
quite what you actually see what you do
see what Francis does here and that this
is honestly this is I'm not a big
Francis Pope Francis fan myself to put
it mildly and I don't support most of
the things that he's or many of the
things that he's said and done this
might be the first thing that he's done
that I support
this right here I
a strange new respect for Pope Francis
I'm totally on Tontine Pope team Pope on
this one
because this was not a violent assault
this was the Pope turning to leave after
greeting probably hundreds of people he
was going down the line it's got to end
somewhere okay if there's 50,000 people
he's not gonna shake every single
person's hand so he's turning it leave
the woman reaches out Greg can you
imagine doing this to the Pope or to
anyone even if it wasn't the Pope
reaches out grabs him Yanks him back and
then this is really important he tries
to pull his hand back three times he
doesn't immediately slap her tits out he
slaps her in the face he doesn't it's
not like she pulls him and he turns
around Bob that doesn't happen
no he's just he's trying to he tries
three times to get his hand free and she
won't let go and then finally he's you
know it's not hard it's just a little a
little it's like a beer if your kids
reach in for the hot stove you might
just do a quick little slap on the wrist
what do you expect keep in mind this is
an 83 year old man likely has arthritis
arthritis likely has arthritis you could
tell that he was in pain and I lemon all
honestly you watch the video if you
freeze frame it right at the moment
where he's yanked in you can see a
visible grimace and also I mean if you
if you've ever if you've ever shook the
hand of a you know 83 year old person
before you know that it's if they don't
often have the firmest grasp because the
their bones are you know not as strong
as they used to be and it's very common
at that age to have arthritis and so
it's gonna be painful so it looks to me
like he's in pain and he's just reacting
instinctively trying to pull his hand
away and she won't let go yet amazingly
or maybe not so amazingly most people
have taken the woman's side on this
which I find mind-boggling so often
these days putting politics aside
because it doesn't seem like there's a
left-right divide here
but so often these days that it seems
like 95% of people are reacting to a
certain thing in a certain way and I
look at that reaction and just it
boggles my mind I don't understand it
how could you see that video and take
the woman's side to try again this is I
think this would be inappropriate to do
to anybody it's just it's not okay to
try to get somebody's attention by
yanking them towards you but imagine
doing it to the Pope imagine doing it to
the president what do you think would
happen what do you think would happen if
the president was walking by and you
reached out and grabbed him and pulled
him towards you and wouldn't let go do
you think I mean you wouldn't get there
wouldn't be any tug-of-war back and
forth like there was in this case and
I'm kind of wondering where was the Pope
security they're just sort of standing
there not doing anything but with the
president you you couldn't make it that
far as soon as soon as your hand made
contact with his wrist you're gonna be
on the ground in a dogpile bum-rushed
bye-bye Secret Service that's the way
that's gonna go and I don't think anyone
would feel sorry for you because
everybody would say what are you doing
grabbing the president what do you think
is gonna happen but as I said Pope or
not Pope you just you don't do that and
if you gret if you do that you grab
somebody and gang come towards you you
deserve to get your hand slapped away
you know I don't care man woman doesn't
matter you just you cuz you have no
right to do that
what is this woman entitled to the
Pope's attention somebody told me
yesterday I was talking about this on
Twitter
and somebody said well she was being
ignored by the Pope I mean ignored by
the Pope she's one face among 50,000
people and so if she doesn't get that
one-on-one time she herself is being
personally ignored
yeah I'm ignored by the Pope - he's
never said hi to me I I mean I've been
ignored by almost everybody on earth by
that standard so the Pope goes and
that's so that's what we're saying huh
she's entitled you're in if the Pope
walks by you are entitled to the Pope's
attention and if he doesn't give it to
you you can grab him and yank him
towards you and if he gets away from you
grab you could tackle him pick him up
like a fireman's carry bring him back to
your to your you know dining room and
force him to have dinner with you I mean
he's a human being it doesn't have to
accept being grabbed by whoever decides
to grab him all right so don't go
grabbing the Pope that's the that's the
lesson here I like by the way also all
these people saying well did this you
know like other Pope's would never other
Pope's would never do this this is
unprecedented for a pope to do this hey
you know there there have been I I think
there probably been a lot of Pope's who
would do that actually or worse
if you grab them JP - maybe not benedict
like i could see it with benedict I
think Bennett did never strike me as the
kind of man that you want to just grab
and yeah you know but there I wouldn't
be so quick to assume that if this was
the Middle Ages and you just did you did
that to a pope
I think it's a slap on the wrist would
be about is the best-case scenario for
you and that in that in that situation
alright you know 2020 is gonna be a
bottomless pit of savage savagery
as we as we watch Democrats attempt to
rip apart the fabric of our political
system in order to get rid of Donald
Trump the best way to stay informed stay
on top of all of it
god help us is to become a daily wire
member and get comprehensive news and
opinion from us on demand and so we're
giving you 20% off all memberships until
January 6th so you've got now in
extension beyond New Year's that's 20%
off all memberships when using promo
code DW 2020 that's DW to 0 to 0 members
get our articles ad free you get access
to all of our live broadcast the show
library the full 3 hours of the Ben
Shapiro show you get bonus content you
get access to the mailbag plus our new
all access to your gets you into live
online Q&A discussions with Ben Andrew
clave and Michael Knowles me plus our
sites writers and special guests also
will do these q and A's and they're very
interesting so if you have a question
you can get an answer again that's promo
code DW to zero to zero for 20% off
until Monday January 6 you got a few
more days you don't want to miss it
again that's until Monday January 6 DW
2024 20% off all right before we get to
emails
Mayor Bill de Blasio's is coming after
Domino's criticizing them for hiking the
prices on their on their pizzas on New
Year's Eve in New York there was a
headline that says Domino's sells $30
pizzas to Times Square ball drop
revelers on New Year's Eve and the mayor
saw this and tweeted jacking up your
prices on on people trying to celebrate
the holidays
classy Domino's to the thousands who
came to Times Square last night to ring
in 2020 I'm sorry this corporate trade
chain exploited you stick it to them by
patronizing one of our fantastic local
pizzerias you know bill de blasio can
never
forfeit an opportunity to embarrass
himself or to do the class warfare stick
and so he's trying to do it here the
problem is this is absurd on a number of
levels number one this was a decision
made by the local franchise not by
corporate Domino's headquarters number
two everything in New York is expensive
it's like the mayor just noticed that
when you go to Times Square things are a
lot more expensive than they are if
you're not in Times Square and number
three so maybe it's just me but 30 bucks
for a pizza isn't even that bad I mean
it's it's bad it's it's more than I
would pay especially for a Domino's
Pizza but I wouldn't be if you had told
me that a large pizza in Times Square on
New Year's Eve costs $50 I would not
have been surprised but number four
here's my primary point anybody dumb
enough to stand in the freezing cold in
Times Square for 11 hours
shoulder-to-shoulder with drunk
strangers with no bathroom in sight just
to see a glowing orb descends slightly
down a pole for 10 seconds deserves to
be exploited in this way I mean you
deserve it that's that's the main thing
I think about this every year when we
watch the ball drop in my house and we
you know we turn it on at like 11 58 and
we watch for two minutes when we turn it
off but I always think why in god's name
do all of these maniacs show up there
just to stand for hours on end in the
cold with drunk people peeing their
pants all around you and the big payoff
is that the shiny thing on the building
like moves location goes from here to
here I still remember I remember my
disappointment the first time that I
watched the ball drop when I was a kid
because for years you know before my
parents let me stay up till midnight to
watch it that was when I was maybe like
8 or 9 or something but for the years
leading up to that I had always heard
about the ball drop and I'd always
wondered you know what it was I'd heard
about this mystical ball drop and
everybody
stays up to watch it and they go and
millions of people I imagine I didn't
know exactly what I was expecting I
guess I thought the ball would be 300
feet in circumference and it would
descend from the clouds and it would
explode and leprechauns riding unicorns
would emerge and grant wishes to
everybody watching that is something
like that but instead I watch it and
what I see is this pathetic little shiny
thing just so ever so slightly adjust
its position on the pole and so that's
the real outrage here not the pizza
it's how pathetic and and in
anti-climactic the ball drop is it's the
year 2020 for God's sakes it's the 20s
for goodness sake we could do better
than that alright let's go to emails
Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt wall
show at gmail.com this is from Julie
says please please address one of the
things that bothers me the most when
people say New Year's it's New Year a
singular noun aiming the day we
celebrate a new year not the New Year's
that would signify multiple years do we
say happy birthdays merry Christmas's
nope just simply Happy New Year when
people say what are you doing for New
Year's they're really and apparently not
aware that they're trying to say what
are you doing for New Year's Eve it
drives me mad
PS Happy New Year yeah Julie see that I
said that I'm a pedantic jerk myself and
this is a now this is a thing that I'm
pedantic about as well and I agree with
you that it's just it's it makes you
sound illiterate when you say New Year's
moving on to Carl says from Cara from
Carl says hi Matt I saw you defending
the Pope on Twitter for beating the
woman who tried to talk to him for
beating the woman who tried to talk to
him honest question WWJD jesus never
responded that way to people isn't that
enough to settle the argument ok Carl
first of all I think you know that your
characterization here is a little bit
ridiculous you
beat anyone didn't beat a woman for
trying to talk to him and but but before
we get to WWJD
what about w w CD okay what would Carl
do think about that what would you do
how would you react if you were walking
down the street and a stranger grabbed
you yanked you towards them wouldn't let
go as you tried to release yourself from
their grasp but three times
wouldn't you be well within your rights
to slap them away or would you just sit
there for obedience as they want to hold
onto you now yeah you know I'm not
saying w w CD what would what would I
you know what would Carl do or what what
I do that's not that's not it doesn't
always justify just because someone's
done something and you say well I would
do the same thing doesn't mean that it's
okay but I am saying that before we pass
judgment on somebody we should think
would I react the same way as for Jesus
first of all you know you can't really
say that he never responded that way to
people somebody made this point on
Twitter yesterday and I think it's
important it's a good point we actually
have no idea what Jesus did or or what
he said for 99.9% of his life you know
for 99.9% of the time that he spent on
earth we have we really don't know what
he did or said we were so you know he
died at 33 we think and the Gospels tell
us a little bit about his birth and then
nothing at all except for one brief
story when he was an adolescent but then
other than that nothing until he gets to
be about 30 or so and even then all of
the Gospels of it put together give us
what I don't know a few dozen scenes of
his life during that time maybe less
than that Jesus lived a life a life
consisting of 24 hours in a day and he
had about 12,000 of those days and we
have no idea what happened during all of
those days except for a few now I'm not
that Jesus was going around slapping the
hell out of people for the rest of the
time that the Gospels don't record I
think probably he wasn't I'm just saying
that you have to be careful with
statements like jesus never did XYZ you
have to be and and I think we all get
loose with that sometimes I know I've
done it too that Jesus never said Jesus
never did what you mean to say is Jesus
is never recorded saying or doing XYZ
which in this case isn't even true
because Jesus did with people at the you
know the the cleansing of the temple we
get that's recorded in all four Gospels
and he drives people out with a whip
that's physical violence that he used
different situation of course but if
you're insinuating that he never you
know physically made contact with
someone in that kind of aggressive way
that's it's not true we know that's not
true because it's recorded in the
Gospels but you know when we talk about
what Jesus never did for the times when
he's not on camera so to speak well we
could say that Jesus never did a sinful
thing so you could say that yeah but and
you could say he never did anything
anachronistic okay it's probably safe to
say that he never played Street Fighter
or watched Breaking Bad or used an
iPhone given the time period that he
lived in but if what we're talking about
is not sinful and it wouldn't be out of
place for the time period he lived in
then we we can't really say that he'd
ever did it
so is it sinful to swat someone's hand
away when they're grabbing you I don't
think it is why would that be sinful and
if it's not and there
about it that's again out of place for
the time period I don't know maybe he
did
can't really say all right from
brian says hi Matt I read your piece
about guns in church and schools be real
about this would you really want to send
your kids to school where people are
toting guns all over the place well the
way that you make it sound no I wouldn't
want that because you're trying to make
it sound like you're going into school
and everybody's got a gun including the
kids and they're all just you know
twirling their pistols in there with
their fingers and stuff like that yeah
of course nobody wants that but would I
want to send my kid to a school where
there are competent adults who know how
to use firearms and are legally carrying
them absolutely
kind of at the point where that's a
prerequisite actually for me sending my
kid to a school I I think I would need
that and as I pointed out many times
public schools are government buildings
and you know we could list dozens of
other types of government buildings that
are guarded by armed security including
even you go to the social service office
to get a new something you know a Social
Security card or something and there's
gonna be a security guard sitting there
with a with a with a gun when's the last
time the Social Security office got got
robbed doesn't happen very often yet you
know there's a there's an armed person
there you go to Congress certainly
there's gonna be armed security so if we
have armed security in government
buildings to protect documents to
protect politicians
why wouldn't we have it to protect
children our own children especially
that doesn't make sense of me this is
from Beth says Matt I'm disappointed in
your take on guns and churches I expect
most conservative pundits to take the
standard talking point lines but you
usually are more thoughtful than that do
you acknowledge that there is a gun
violence epidemic in our country if so
how can you deny that reducing the
number of guns will at least have some
positive effect on reducing the epidemic
well Beth I don't acknowledge the gun
violence epidemic as you put it and I'll
tell you why because 60% of the gun
deaths every year are suicides 60% now I
do think there's a suicide epidemic and
that's a big problem but hopefully you
would agree that guns have almost
nothing to do with it people might
choose to use a gun to kill themselves
if there's one available but do you
think you could permanently stop
somebody from killing themselves just by
keeping them away from a gun well I
think obviously not any more than you
could permanently stop someone from
killing themselves by keeping them away
from you know pills or high ledges or
you know ropes or any of the other ways
that people use to
so it's a I think it's clearly absurd to
blame guns for suicides and I don't
think that suicides can get lumped into
the gun violence epidemic statistic I
think it's extremely misleading because
when we hear about the gun violence
epidemic obviously what comes
immediately to mind is murder and it
sounds like when you say there's a gun
violence epidemic it sounds like you're
saying there's an epidemic of people
going into buildings or walking across
the street or whatever and using a gun
to kill somebody else or multiple people
that certainly is is is the impression
that's given to us but when you look at
the numbers and what comprises most of
the so-called gun violence epidemic it
is suicide and so that's why it's
misleading now if you take out suicide
you're left with maybe 10 or 15 thousand
homicides by gun every year in the u.s.
in a population of 330 million so that's
one in every what 33,000 people another
way to look at this a football stadium
typically fits 70,000 people so in any
given football stadium packed to the
rafters two of the people in that whole
stadium will die by gun homicide in
their life and that actually I think
makes it seem worse than it is because
there's there's a very good chance that
in any given stadium nobody in the whole
building is gonna die by by gun violence
because the inner city accounts for a
disproportionate amount of the gun
homicides so it's not like this is a
problem spread evenly throughout the US
but any way you look at it you know I
don't think 10,000 in a country of 330
million counts as an epidemic the only
way that 10,000 homicides in a country
of 330 million can be called an epidemic
is if you're starting from from with an
assumption or a hope or a belief that
nobody will be murdered in a country of
330 million so if your expectation is
zero and you end and then you look in
it's ten thousand well yeah that's an
epidemic but if you begin with an
understanding of human nature and an
acknowledgment that murder will happen
and that it does happen in every country
no matter what then you have to ask
yourself
realistically best-case scenario what
should the the murder rate be
you know what I'm saying is well if I
mean we talked before about should and
should it so if we're talking ideally in
an ideal utopian scenario what should
the murder rate be well in that case yes
it should be zero but realistically
practically speaking in the real world
in a country of 330 million
what should the murder rate but you
can't say zero because that's not at all
realistic or practical because then
you're not talking about the real world
you're talking about a fantasy utopia
which doesn't exist so that's my
question to you do you think 10,000 is
an epidemic well what I mean what are
you thinking it could even if we got rid
of all the guns what would you expect
the murder rate to be 5,000 I think
wherever you put it 10,000 maybe is a
little higher than what you would like
or what what what you think we can get
it the number to but it's not at
epidemic levels in comparison to your
realistic expectations now it's bad
obviously every murder is bad every
violent death is a horrible thing and
I'm not saying we should just accept it
for what it is what I'm saying is we
need to be reasonable and rational and
realistic in the way that we discuss it
we have to avoid sensationalism and
that's that's my thing but going back to
the numbers so most of the gun deaths
are suicides then you've got this
minority of cases where it's a homicide
by a gun a disproportionate number of
those are inner-city drug and gang
related and the crucial point there is
that most of that violence is by people
who illegally obtained the guns to begin
with so you can't make it more illegal
if somebody illegally has a gun and they
go commit a murder well they've done two
illegal things I don't think you can
make those things any more illegal than
they already are so additional laws and
regulations on top of that probably
won't do anything so I think what you
really have to look at when we talk
about gun regulations and the viol the
so-called violence epidemic and so on
what you have to look at are cases where
legal guns
owned by registered gun owners are used
to murder another person
and that is a very small percentage of
the overall gun violence statistic and
in that very small percentage given that
much of it most of it the vast majority
of it is from domestic disputes I don't
see how regulations against guns would
do anything you know unless you're
talking about trying to confiscate every
gun and get rid of all the guns which
you can't do constitutionally and
hopefully if you are living in the real
world you realize that you can't do it
feasibly and practically either so if
we're not talking about that about that
if you're but if you're trying to be
reasonable talking about things that we
could feasibly and within the framework
of the Constitution do I don't see how
anything you could do would would would
would prevent most of the you know
murders that are committed by legal gun
owners because you know if if a guy in a
drunken rage kills his wife well if he
had never committed a crime before that
and before that point he was a
law-abiding citizen and an adult and all
that then on what basis would you deny
him his right to own the gun this isn't
the Minority Report we can't look into
the future yeah that we could talk about
red flags and so on but if the red flag
is not a crime being committed or you
know someone being committed to a mental
institution because they're completely
insane I mean if that's not the red flag
then I don't and what can you do and so
that's that's my my stance on it I just
don't see I think the when you're
talking about gun violence epidemic I
think it's that's sensationalist
nonsense and it's just not true
and even though all murder is obviously
bad and we all agree on that and we
would all like to see fewer murders I
just don't see how additional
regulations on top of the regulations
that exist will do anything
especially when you consider that you
know inner cities are again the
disproportionate number of gun homicides
happen there and those are the places
usually where you have the strictest gun
laws in places like Baltimore in Chicago
so I think that's what you have to I try
to be you know I don't but I'm not this
isn't this isn't me spouting talking
points nothing I'm saying here is a
talking point now these might be points
that conservatives often raise I'm not
saying that I've I've come up with some
bold new argument or anything but this
isn't these are just I'm trying to
rationally and reasonably work through
this and that's how I work through it it
doesn't make any difference to me that
it's among conservatives the standard
position is to be pro gun and progam is
a standard one I don't care about the
standard position this is just how it
seems to me you can tell me where you
think I've gone wrong I'd like to hear
all right thanks everybody for watching
thanks for listening will leave it there
God's be
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]